this is hollywood makeup wizard
kevin yeager and these wrinkles on his
face
aren't real they were actually created
with a method called stippling
which deepens the crow's feet around his
eyes
from sculpting enlarged earlobes to
painting broken veins it's just one of
the many ways he can make performers
like keanu reeves look
95 years old kevin draws inspiration
from many classic old age makeup looks
in movies but he gets much of his
material
just by observing people in the real
world when he turned alex winter into
granny preston for bill and ted's bogus
journey back in 1991
he was inspired by his mother-in-law she
had these great
apple cheeks she had that classic granny
look to her face
when he had to make alex and keanu look
like they were 95 years old and bill and
ted face the music
he started with these photoshop concepts
with kian i wanted to give him like an
iggy pop
skinnier older aged rocker look and with
alex i wanted to get in
your friendly disposition every
prosthetic related look
starts with life casts since only alex
and keanu's bare necks
faces and arms were visible on camera
kevin didn't need prosthetics for their
entire bodies
instead only the actors heads and arms
were covered in purple and green
silicone rubbers
the green silicone has an oil in it that
ensures it won't pull any of the actors
hairs out of their bodies
the impressions are then wrapped in
temporary plaster to hold them together
before being cast in hydrocal and
urethane
the life casting process helps a makeup
artist replicate the little details of a
performer's skin
but when it came to alex and keanu's old
age looks the life casts also helped
kevin find and exaggerate wrinkles
already forming on their faces and
forearms just kind of studied their
the lines of their faces and to see
where you know droopage starts
how this jowls will begin to form his
nasolabial folds
becoming more prominent you know his eye
sockets are deepening a slight bit
to mimic the fine details of old skin he
added clay to the busts of alex and
keanu's faces and forearms
which allowed him to sculpt directly on
the skin
this was where kevin could add wrinkles
and veins that really stick out
and different ages don't look the same
while kevin made alex and keanu look 95
here
in the movie blow he made johnny depp
look just a bit older than he already
was aging the actor from his late 30s
into his 60s
as you can see there are still aged
features on his face
but less pronounced the pores on the 95
year old skin
look more elongated something kevin
observed and mimicked while creating
texture
as you get older they begin to stretch
with your skin kevin and his team also
had to create really pronounced wrinkles
for bill and ted
they achieved this by cross hatching all
over the character's forearms and faces
but they changed up their technique on
different parts of the body chin is kind
of funny because it gets a lot of weird
cross hatching wrinkles in them and
wrinkles around the eyes
or crow's feet required a different
pattern too an effect that they could
also achieve through stippling
stippling is done by simply adding a
latex based liquid to the skin
and powdering it it stretches the skin
and causes these wrinkles
kevin used this technique on pete
possible's weight to create wrinkles
around his eyes when the actor had to
play a character who was hundreds of
years old in eon flux
i didn't have to do any age to him as
far as like accentuate all the things i
did to these guys he had a hat in his
face but he was wasn't old enough
the body doesn't just wrinkle as you age
when you get to be 95
your bones begin to show meaning your
sockets get deeper
kevin made sure bone was visible when
sculpting their hands
because bill and ted were so old he also
wanted them to look arthritic
a trait that shows up especially in the
hands you get this curved look i can't
do much about that but what i could do
is exaggerate these knuckles you can see
a fine little bone in between each
knuckle and the knuckles are swollen
and going farther up the arm he even
made the wrist bone stand out
once kevin and his team sculpted all the
details they created another set of
negatives and then poured silicone into
those
molds and sandwiched it all together
silicone is necessary for perfectly
mimicking the translucency and texture
of skin
as you can see here it also naturally
wrinkles like old human skin would
the color of the silicone is already
intrinsically colored to be a flesh tone
and you can see
light through this if i could get that
the right angle
but it's not until additional colors are
added that all the sculpted wrinkles and
bones and pores begin to look
realistic kevin started with a basic
skin color palette of green
and a heavy emphasis on red meanwhile
the thinning hairs punched into keanu's
head weren't a solid gray they were
actually a mix of white and yellow
when looking at the eyes kevin knew that
the color around the eye sockets
darkens with age and airbrushing in
shadow helps the sculpted areas really
pop
making the bone structure much more
visible while veins are usually sculpted
kevin also elevated them through
airbrushing this tool was
especially helpful for the aging veins
on their faces like on
alex and keanu's muscle suits kevin can
airbrush on details like pores
but for their old age he needed to add
even more decay to the skin
these delicate imperfections like these
purple and red capillaries on keanu's
prosthetic nose
needed to be painted by hand he has to
do the same with liver spots but they
are bigger and more noticeable a lot of
them are tiny little breakups little
tiny dots like freckles and then i
most likely hand paint all the all the
liver spots when you get to be bigger
spots like
in some of these pieces i'll actually go
back in and hand paint all the bigger
ones and i'll place those exactly where
i want them to be
tiny aging freckles also make the skin
look older
he found that for some of those he could
easily get lots on at once by taking a
chip brush
and flicking it
for face the music kevin added
additional layers of makeup to the
actors that might seem like
overkill but they really sell the look
and bring out the kinds of aging details
you might never think of
for example when people get older their
noses and ears often enlarge
kevin estimates that he had to make alex
and keanu's ears and noses about
20 bigger than their normal size it
wasn't just the skin that had to look
old
on face the music kevin realized he
could make alex look old by giving him
cataracts
so kevin used these glassy looking
contact lenses that gave alex
foggy eyes now if they were too opaque
alex would have looked blind
while cataracts have more of a milky
look old man
young man well almost young old sort of
young
cold kind of old and by using a simple
combo of glue and thickener
you could apply fake eye bags to keanu
on set
like stickers almost and you just put
them down and you kind of blend the
edges quicker
the attention to both the big details
and especially all those little ones
that only an artist could think of
surprised even the actors themselves
throughout several decades of doing old
age makeup kevin has found the key to
getting it right
knowing that it's imperfect the great
thing about old age makeups is that the
stakes are welcome
they're messy and they're flawed